the braves ace right-hander mike soroka
on the mound and jd davis is going to be
the batter nothing in one pitch on the
way to jd davis ground ball chopped out
to dansby taking on three hops an easy
little toss to ozzy at second for the
force out of cadeau and that ends the
top of the first inning on the mount for
the match their ace two-time cell young
winner jacob degrom two down here in the
inning and there's freddie freeman the
ground with a left leg kick here's the
pitch swung on and missed strike three
so he changed up on him on owen two and
freddy freeman can only humble to
himself and again we'll see if the meds
can take advantage here first and third
nobody out no score
and michael conforto's the battery he
grounded to first his first time
righty to lefty soroka's pitch
michael strokes one the other way that's
down for a base hit rosario comes in
with the game's first run nimmo racing
for third conforto heads for second as
the throw went to third and it's a
double for conforto and the mets lead
one nothing
still nobody out a run is in base is
loaded for canoe who drew a walk his
first time up
grounds went over the back that's a fair
ball going down the line nemo is in
conforto right behind him he will score
it's a two-run single for robinson canoe
and the mets have put up a three spot
with nobody out in the third it's
three-nothing new york
matter now is jd davis
who hit into a fielder's choice his
first time
grab ball down to first freeman with a
nice sprawling stop gets the out there's
nobody covering it first soroka might
have hurt himself trying to go and cover
first base and he gets him he's limping
mike soroka went down in a heap and he
is limping toward the foul line
and he is on two knees
on the infield grass oh no
and that is of great consequence for the
atlanta braves
and he is going to be helped off the
field holding his right foot up in the
air this looks terrible the bases are
loaded again one out
as wilson ramos will be the batter 2-2
coming and ramos pokes one to center
field that's going to fall for a base
hit alonso in to score everybody else
will move up a base
and the mets now lead at four or nothing
so ramos lines a single up the middle
into center field
and the mets take a four nothing lead
here in the third
with two outs it's back where it all
started with the med rosario the 01.
on the ground bad hop camargo's got it
thought about a tag and the throw to
first is in time the top of the third
was the worst half inning the braves
have experienced in a very very long
time the mets send ten men to the plate
and score four for the ground
it's a plethora jake
though ahmed rosario the latest player
to leave this game because of apparent
injury rosario made the last out
in the last inning here's canelo a
two-run base hit his last time
you know one for three against russian
and he hits that toward the middle base
hit
conforto to third he's going to be waved
around inciarte unleashes the throat of
the plate it's cut off and now they have
alonso and a rundown and freeman tags
him out that enables kanoa to get to
second
so it's an rbi single for canoe he
drives in his third run of the night to
make it five nothing so the mets have a
run home here in the fourth canoe at
second with two out for jd davis
line drive one hopper what a play
knocked down by dansby but it'll trickle
out into shallow left
on his way to the plate as canoe the
throw to the plate and they got him what
a nice comeback by dansby
to hustle out there and shallow left
field get the ball and then throw a
strike to home plate and get canoe
he had a base in his last time up picked
up his first rbi of the year
there's wilson ramos who hit a single up
the middle to drive in a run his last
time up and he gets under this one to
right center back goes in ciarte to the
warning track and the wall it's out of
here
wilson ramos with his first home run of
the season
a two-run shot
ramos who came into the night without it
run batted in for the year has three
tonight and the mets now lead at seven
to nothing robinson canoe who has been
swinging the bat extremely well has come
out
and brian dozier has come in bottom half
of the fit for atlanta will send up
darneau swanson and camargo
here's his 1-1
high flying ball walloped toward the
left center field gap that ball was
really stung and it's gone home run
darneau braves are on the board seven to
one
and darneau turned one around from his
old battery mate
these two for two off of him and that's
his first homer in a braves uni so back
to the top of the order now and ronald
acuna junior three balls two strikes
swinging a shot to left field that's
going to get down and score a run ender
will come around great at bat by ronald
acuna jr and the braves have a two spot
here in the fifth inning
and it is seven to two new york
so the number two hitter ozzy orbeez
will be the batter
one two coming and albies goes down
swinging and that retires the side nine
strikeouts for degrom but the braves
score two to get back closer seven two
mets after five
a very unhappy jacob degrom
and so now luke jackson is gonna face jd
davis payoff pitch to davis swung on
bounce toward short two hopper to dansby
gloves throws got him and the inning is
over travis star no homer does last time
up
door goes down swinging on up and in at
99 10 strikeouts for degrom robinson
canola left the game with left groin
tightness ahmed rosario also left the
game with left quad tightness and jeff
mcneal was a late scratch because of
lower back tightness and the inning
continues for luis guillermo
gormay with a chopper up the middle
dansby hard to the right side of second
gloves and throws over the first base
and that's in time for the out nice play
defensively by swanson
they are loaded here with two down in
the bottom of the seventh wilson versus
freeman
freddy hits one on the ground down to
alonso he takes it himself wilson gets a
king-sized out and keeps the meds in
front by five
and thus the braves are down to their
final out of the night with ronald
lacuna coming up
3-2 from hughes to acuna
he struck him out and the ball game is
over
jared hughes at his mets debut goes the
last two innings to finish it off for
jacob degrom jake gets his first win of
the year conforto with three hits ramos
with his first home run of the year and
the mets snap a five-game losing streak
as they salvage the finale in atlanta
winning tonight seven to two